that was great we got it
the cast of the harry potter franchise
were all perfectly behaved behind the
scenes
i'm an angel i'm an angel okay
maybe not but they did share some sweet
moments on set
as well as some potentially dangerous
ones if you've ever wondered how slugs
taste
or how ginny coped with being trapped in
the chamber of secrets we'll fill you in
are you so determined to embarrass me
ginny waited so long for harry to
finally return her affections but bonnie
wright wanted to wait even
longer before locking lips with daniel
radcliffe apparently
they both felt it was strange to smooch
someone they'd grown up with which made
each actor nervous
needless to say they didn't quite get
this in one take
it took quite a few the first year
bonnie estimates that their nerves
caused them to redo this scene
30 times before harry and ginny's first
kiss looked convincing in the half-blood
prince the lesson bonnie learned from
this when it comes to kissing
or just filming a kiss sometimes you
just have to go for it
we had fun doing it it was we joked
about you know
speaking of awkward on-set kisses tons
of fans were excited to see hermione and
ron lock lips for the first time
or at least we're willing to put up with
it in exchange for never having to hear
lavender say
again but behind the scenes rupert grint
and emma watson were both
dreading it since they considered
themselves siblings at that point
believe me we both want it to be over
equally as much as the other as clever
as hermione
emma came up with a plan she knows that
rather than doing 27 takes
she knew if she committed really early
we'd get it
she wasn't about to do 30 takes like
bonnie and daniel so she threw herself
at rupert right away
once we did it it was nice we know
daniel radcliffe can act
but can he dance you might not know what
to believe after seeing this clip of him
and shefali chaudhry at the u-ball
in harry potter and the goblet of fire
we learned even witches and wizards have
school dances full of drama
apparently it took a little time for
harry and privati to get their moves
right on set it is just a reversal
later daniel claimed to be a fantastic
dancer but because harry's not very good
i felt like a player
is he a really bad dancer or a really
good actor
ron's brothers fred and george are
notorious troublemakers but rupert was
the real problem on set
sometimes stars couldn't help but giggle
during a scene and
every cast member in the harry potter
franchise is guilty of this
but no one caused as many disruptions as
rupert
you shouldn't be laughing at the end
when you find out that dan's going to
potentially be
killed by safe his laughter distracted
his co-stars
i can see rupert laughing in the mirror
i can see i can hear him snickering in
my ear
frustrated the crew rupert will start
giggling and
you pretend he isn't giggling and ended
up causing the need for a penalty system
for unsanctioned laughter
red card bonnie was forced to pay up
during the half-blood prince
during the scene in which ginny brings
harry a mince pie because she just
couldn't stop
giggling in harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone first year hogwarts
students learn how to fly brooms for the
first time
playing hand games might not be quite as
exciting as soaring through the sky on
brooms but it made for some
adorable behind the scenes moments
apparently emma couldn't help but take
playtime seriously and her cast members
noticed a competitive streak
right away i'm a forever competitive
person
emma slapping hands with tom felton was
so cute we can't believe she was
smacking him
in the face just a few years after this
hermione no
it's not worth it but don't let emma
watson fool you
she's a competitive and clever person
but that doesn't mean she can't be bad
once in a while
this star has broken character due to
laughter quite a few times
and was seen using her cell phone while
on set on the bed
with her shoes on everyone knows
electronics don't work at hogwarts emma
as much as we love the movies they can't
incorporate every
element from the books even if we don't
like to admit it one of the things cut
from the films was hermione's oversized
front teeth but it turns out emma did
have some at least for a while
according to sorcerer's stone director
chris columbus emma is actually wearing
false teeth
during this scene but he realized she
couldn't keep acting with them in her
mouth
oh are you doing magic let's see then
what's more difficult than trying to get
a big group of kids to cooperate on set
how about trying to keep them in line
when they're flying through the air
that was a real problem thanks to all
those quidditch matches and when we saw
dueling in harry potter and the chamber
of secrets
maybe that's why harry usually sticks to
a simple disarming spelliamor
as you might have guessed based on this
scene we talked about earlier
there was no love lost between hermione
and draco not unless we're talking about
germaine fanfiction
but behind the scenes emma admits she
had a huge crush on tom felton when they
were kids
that's right during the first two films
hermione was really smitten with draco
the entire time
some people think emma and tom are
dating in real life but he claims that
when he found out about her crush
i heard it through the grapevine and
then eventually you know we became
we became good friends poor emma had to
film her scene on the hogwarts express
with fake teeth while rupert and daniel
got to stuff
their mouths with candy i got every
single flavor
well hopefully not every flavor george
sweared he got a bogey flavored one once
apparently nobody ever told daniel not
to play with his food
get a snake turn it into daniel
radcliffe and rupert grint are friends
in real life but on set they had a few
differences
apparently rupert was a little bit shy
and didn't want to be seen while he was
getting his hair and makeup done
rather not be seen like this yeah
meanwhile daniel had no problem wearing
some
different clothes during harry potter
and the deathly hallows
wow we're identical ron learned about
the dangers of a broken wand the hard
way
when he ended up cursing himself with a
slug vomiting charm in chamber of
secrets
we know ron didn't have a lot of fun
being cursed but rupert didn't exactly
enjoy it either
for rupert this movie moment was the
most challenging part of the franchise
at that point he had to put
slimy plastic slugs in his mouth and
then well you know
don't worry there was at least one
upside to filming this scene
but it tasted quite nice actually in
order to make the process a little bit
easier
the crew made sure to add flavoring to
the slime so rupert was tasting
chocolate fruit
and peppermint apparently harry potter
and the chamber of secrets was full of
challenges for the cast
and bonnie wright struggled to get
through one of the scenes ginny weasley
has a bigger part in the second movie
but unfortunately that was because she
was being tormented by
you know who she ended up in the chamber
of secrets laying on a very cold marble
floor
according to bonnie the floor was so
freezing that she couldn't handle laying
on it for long enough to film the scene
so in order to get her through it the
crew hid hot water bottles in her
clothes to keep her warm
his poor genie grows weaker emma watson
has had tons of success
both within the harry potter franchise
and outside of it but there was a time
when filming harry potter and the
deathly hallows part 2
she actually missed her mark literally
escaping gringotts wasn't easy behind
the scenes either but at least there
wasn't a real dragon
then behind the scenes bloopers are one
thing but helena bonham carter did some
real damage to one of her co-stars while
working on harry potter and the order of
the phoenix
bellatrix lestrange has a real mean
streak while helena's harm was entirely
accidental during one scene bellatrix
gets her hands on neville longbottom and
puts him in peril in front of his
friends
it turns out actor matthew lewis was in
real danger of her wand
matthew moved while helena was poking
her wand at his ear and the two collided
ouch matthew ended up with a perforated
eardrum and didn't come clean about what
happened for three days
don't worry the pain and hearing loss
was temporary although the jokes
kept on going helena says she would
always shout to ask matthew if he was
all right after this
don't give it too hard which one of
these behind the scenes moments was your
favorite do you think the cast was
perfect together or would you have
preferred some other stars instead
let us know what you think in the
comment section below and make sure to
click on the subscribe button for more
new videos from us here at the things
we'll see you next time
you